but if time permits we'll bring that up
later salad bar earlier and I you know
what I lost that fight and capela duck
sit down game is tied at two they
shooting 38% from three shooting about
four to half threes per game what a make
that was hardened to Westbrook catch and
shoot in rhythm
that's where rust can make the three
he's one of the big reasons why the
Phoenix Suns are playing so well this
year he's been a big surprise harden
with the right hand splitting the two
defenders a lot of contact on that shot
harden on the rookie pulls back shoots
over the outstretched arms and sticks it
Pam Johnson trying to get it back
Kaminsky climbed the back give rivers
who wanted to call the whistle that hard
it right down Broadway split two
defenders again now else he's gotten
he's happy with but there's James just
using his strength to get all the way to
the bag all the way to the basket harden
again on the rookie pulled back fires
this one
I was going to say that was too long
by the way James Hart has 15 points just
saying James Harden has more than 15
points just saying he's got 18 health
met the previous four seasons with
Charlotte Flores Sonic is a free agent
this past summer with the Suns Westbrook
off one foot tough shot it goes in so
Russ is now 3 of 5 and has 7 point and
now look at the sun's in a 2-3 zone on
the out of bounds play a lot oh well
took the best of passes and capela reach
back and watched it came up high see how
Kaminsky comes up to the ball and that
opens up capela
on that graphic throughout the season he
continues to get better and better
he had offseason knee surgery here he
goes again and river is with the
transition to Westbrook on bridges the
up paint got him to bite and he banked
it up it in three-point opportunity on
the way for Russell Westbrook when they
traded for Westbrook they knew they'd
have an MVP on the floor at all times
and last season James Horton had to
carry the load Westbrook
to McLemore contested quarter three
rivers with the deflection rockets
forced to turn over Westbrook just looks
so energetic confidence cried
that's good play out of timeout to get
Cobo a layup leo
that was an even better play even better
what a great pass from Westbrook some
Aron Baynes kind of reminds me up a
little bit well here's the alley-oop and
Daniel house gets way up off the ground
extraordinaire to the couch in the truck
for the assistant aren't dancing on cam
Johnson jump through the lane and Oh
hung on the rim minute fell three pretty
good shot there by the young man a
pretty good defense by the rocket Mac
the board's coming in to help on the
floor it's important Oh Cobo had Baynes
flashing to the rim now they get it to
him and had it knocked out of his hands
by West forget a guard on to the big guy
so Westbrook is out match right there
was strength but he's able to use his
athleticism to at least block it from
behind and to see the amazing jacket
once again Calvin Murphy nothing is
sparkly and one and one absorbent he is
a historic scorer and you see right
there the rookie on an island with James
Harden doesn't feel good right there and
if you reach he'll get the call every
time counted
Ross what profit capella screamed
triple-teamed
and that leaves PJ Tucker open PJ's
shooting 41% all that space for hard to
drive
so he'll shoot the tree instead number
five it's a it's a weapon I mean it's
unguardable it's like steel westbrook
one man to beat
it's nice to see house in LA event
tonight kind of get back on track
offensively with his shot as westbrook
tucker knocked it for hooker got it back
and then threw it to Westbrook ahead to
house caught it over the shoulder and
then reversed it up and in in transition
here's some defense from PJ Tucker
closing down the lane get in the loose
ball starting the fast break good pass
ahead from Westbrook now watch this
finish that is not easy
James Harden one the best post defenders
in the NBA Westbrook to the rim
timeout Phoenix attack injured in
one-on-one situations as well Westbrook
attack scores how you gonna stop back
Steph Curry has a fifty forty five
ninety season
that's it same Clark
patches fires another three
[Applause]
turn around Westbrook off one foot
popped out he's got a high arcing shot
Dundee House open drain Oh time out Suns
[Applause]
still with it goes in to beat the shot
clock there's two threes ago where it
was really struggling to get the ball to
dribble right and then he just had to
shoot it up as the shock
[Applause]
again shot clocks winding down the here
44 Hardin town how far is this when he
shot this from Tucson he's able to coach
I'm screwed for a few years they're
gonna be good yeah they're the youngest
team in the league in terms of average
age gonna be three straight oh we can't
yes it can behind the three-point line
and Johnson gets up underneath them
amazing
again they sent the double leaving
McLemore wide open and he sticks it 17
triples for the Houston Rockets fumbles
it steps back there it goes
and there it goes begging him to do it
again and he did
he's got 47 now